en la actualidad el cáncer de seno es la
forma de cáncer más común en las mujeres
el hecho de que conozca más sobre la
anatomía de sus propios se nos puede
ayudar con la detección temprana del
cáncer de seno y su prevención sus senos
están unidos a pequeñas masas de tejido
llamadas ganglios linfáticos mediante
vasos linfáticos los ganglios linfáticos
se encargan de acumular bacterias
células cancerígenas y cualquier otro
material poco saludable existen grupos
de estos ganglios linfáticos debajo de
los brazos por encima de las clavículas
y detrás del esternón como también en
otras partes del cuerpo
cada seno tiene lóbulos lobulillos y
conductos los lóbulos constan de
pequeños lobulillos que contienen grupos
de diminutas glándulas productoras de
leche cuando un seno está produciendo
leche esta pasa por los conductos hasta
el pezón desde donde sale del cuerpo el
cáncer de seno se desarrolla con
frecuencia en los lobulillos glándulas y
conductos del pecho